welcome
everybody thank you for joining us for
today's
presentation titled lung cancer gene
fusion assays
using hamstring encounter technology
it is my pleasure to introduce to you dr
noemi reward
dr noemi reward is a medical oncologist
from the department of medical oncology
of hospital clinic here in barcelona
and she's also leading the lung cancer
unit
at our hospital for a complete biography
on our speaker please visit the tab at
the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
and our speaker will respond back to you
by email so please join me in welcoming
dr noemi reward i will now turn the
presentation
over to her
hello thank you so much for this kind
invitation to participate in this
spiritual
conference hosted by nanostring it's a
pleasure to be here
my name is noemi reguar and i'm going to
talk about
our experience on in lung cancer
gene vision detection by using
nanostring
encounter technology here are my
personal disclosures
so here's the online of my presentation
we are going to
put in perspective which are the current
needs in lung cancer management
we are going to go through the
opportunities that encounter provides us
in terms of molecular lung cancer
detection
and we are going to go through our key
results by
ending up by showing how the data has
impacted in the clinical outcomes of our
patients
so let's start with the first part which
are the current needs in lung cancer so
during the last year we have witnessed
dramatical changes in the way we are
approaching lung cancer
therapy we have moved from an astrology
based uh
therapeutic strategy to a molecular
driven one
and among the different subsets of
histology adenocarcinoma and squamous
cell carcinoma then a carcinoma is the
one that has benefit most
benefit most from these targeted
approaches because
around 60 of adenocarcinoma of the lung
harbor oncogenic driven alterations with
potential
for target inhibitors so um
the merchants of targeted therapies have
revolutionized the landscape of
treatment for
lung lung cancer along with
immunotherapy
and currently the detection of these
gene alterations is very important
because
they are going to tell us which patients
can be
in the which patients can receive an
individualized treatment with the
targeted approach
this is why molecular testing has been
uh
introduced introduced in the uh routine
world cup of our language
patients diagnosed along with other
imaging techniques or histology
techniques so
this is an important step a diagnosis
in all patients with non-squamous
advanced non-small cell lung cancer
patients
and because target therapies are very
important
several gene molecular guidelines are
today are recommending the
identification
of uh leading four-leaning oncogenes
those are easier far
and better of mutations and two gene
fissions
[Music]
why they recommend to use an optional
test
a list of other genes which are
important because they are likely going
to approach clinical practice in the
future
those include for example infusions in
red
and drag or mutations in meth
among these genetic alterations in lung
cancer there are several some of them
are
point uh mutations and dna but others
are
gym fusions and among all these
infusions
are rose one red and the track the
standard alone
techniques for detections fda approved
right now are fish and immunostore
chemistry
however we are facing now a new
necessity
that means that we are not just uh need
to test for one gene for all for us rows
of red
but we have to test for several genes
around
seven sixteenths that can receive
targeted therapies so this is why
multiplex markers
molecular testing with uh techniques
such as
ngs or in this case manuscripting can be
useful
and can are being more frequently
incorporated
incorporated in routine clinical
practice
so let's move to the other part which
are the
opportunities that encounter offers for
um uh gene driver detection
in lung cancer so i'm going to just
give an overview of encounter uh
technology because probably
other speakers are going to give more
data about it
but um encounter technologies that
it's transcriptomic system analysis
which
uh can analyze several genes in one
single tube
it doesn't need any enzymatic reactions
and it works by using one color code
barcode which a lot with for um
which allowed for a digital
quantification
this is the methodology and workflow
workflow for nanostring
um
analysis i have to say that this is a
very stride forward technique
semi-automatic it's flexible in terms of
sample input it means that we can use
several sample formaldehyde
fix perfect embedded sample or even cell
blocks it has a really fast turnaround
we have the results in three days which
is very important
when we are talking about advanced lung
cancer patients
which need to have the results very fast
to
start treatment as soon as possible and
it's
low hands on time
nanostring nanostring uses
two approaches for the detection of the
infusions
that i remember said that are very
common
for in lung cancer uh oncogenic
alterations and the nano stream uses two
techniques the first one
is a fusion target specific assay
and the second one and very useful one
is a three five brahma
imbalance assay we by um
designing a specific capture and report
and report uh props that are located
upstream
and the stream of the fusion junction
the technique can
detect the imbalance the right imbalance
between
both probes and detect which patients
have a break point
site and which samples are or which
tumors
have a gene rearrangement
this is our encounter experience and
i like this slide because it seems that
we started yesterday but we started back
six years back six years uh now we
started in 2014 and dr
prank kindly um invited to to
test it for lung cancer patients so i'm
very
glad he gave us this opportunity so we
started in 2014
and since then we have moved forward we
first
retrospectively evaluated the technique
in advanced language and surveys
and our last award that has been to
prospect literally
evaluate the clinical usefulness in
clinical practice
so let's start with our retrospective
validation that was published in 2017
in um in biochem clinical chemistry
journal so in here we started the
assignment
designing our own costume designed
code tax set with which included
51 probes that were designed to
identify um several variants for
gene fusion's attack rose 1 and red
here is the patient court of our study
it included natural story i don't see it
very well but it included a total of
98 patients that was a this was a very
rich population uh set of patients
because
the majority was were positive for all
rush
or red fusions and so sorry i go back
and we uh corroborate
the results with the other approved
techniques for detection which are fish
and in monster chemistry so we first
um evaluate which were the sample
program
requirements for for threshold and
um uh evaluation
with nankans in with nanostring
and we um we observed that as you can
see here
as for immunochemistry and fish the
cell number it's uh required it's around
50 to 100
tumor cells for a nanostring as well for
other multiplexer techniques such a next
generation
sequencing then the number of cells
required
are higher around 60 60 600
600 or 1000 tumor cells
and regarding rna which is very
important
and for nanostring encounter
detection the optimum minimum amount of
rna we identified was 200 nanograms
however i want to point out that we had
several samples
with a minimum amount of 25 nanograms
that also resulted positive for
uh gene fusion detections here's a
representation of our results
very i'm not going to go through each
fusion but
just to show that the nanostring could
identify
arc rose and red positive fusion
alterations and you can see here uh how
nicely the technique can
identify the different partners or
variants associated for
each fusion gene then
importantly we wanted to we aimed to
see which was our reproducibility of
data by comparing it with the standard
techniques
fish and munozo chemistry and as you can
see here the concordance of nanostring
with immunochemistry was very high
almost equal around here
96 percent and very important the
sensitivity
for the detection of addition fusions
compared to
fish was higher with nanostring
indeed among the 11 cases that were
positive for fish for the 11 discordant
cases
with fish and nanostring we could
corroborate that
10 of these and negative fish negative
samples
were positive with the monostochemistry
so
we could recover 10 patients that
otherwise could not have been
identified by the standard fish
technique we then aim to prospectively
evaluate the the nano stream technology
into but uh in the routine world cup
of uh advanced non-small cell lung
cancer patients
and to do so we decided to extend
our tax set and we
created or designed a second coat set
with
72 plots that included other genes among
them
and tracked and met exon 14 skipping
mutations which are important is
in which several targeted therapies are
having really nice results and are going
to be soon incorporated in clinical
practice
so this is what we have done till now we
have
evaluated a lot of samples with
nanostream
a total of 470 samples for a total of
405
patients with advanced non-small cell
lung cancer
and important here to show uh how
um uh only a five percent of those
patients
wearing sufficient head insufficient
material for detection which is a very
low rate and this is very important
because uh
metastatic advancing on a small cell
lung cancer patient normally have
a very low material which is obtained
from a small biopsy needle aspirations
and here i have i wanted to put you
uh it's not going to go to the
specifically detail
i just wanted to show you the uh
normalized
um ratio for the imbalance detection
for each of the gene fusions you have
here for red
for uh for n-track
for rose and for arc
fusion genes and as you can see here for
some genes the positivity of detection
was
seen very nicely the variety of the
imbalance was
very differentiated to other negative or
wild-type
patients and a few samples
mainly in those patients having all
fusions and gross fusions as you can see
here
the post-positive cases were really
close to the
threshold for positivity this is why
with we decided to do
our own algorithm for validating those
cases that we
that were very close to the threshold
and we consider them
equivocal so right now for those for
negative patients um with nanostring we
are not doing
further testing for those patients that
are equivocal
we are validating them with an
orthogonal fish
or um immunochemistry testing and we are
also validating the positive cases as
for
um exploratory analysis
for all positive cases with nanostream
and here also a nice picture we have had
everything we have had
patients detected by um
encounter with al which is the most one
of the most cosmogen fusions but
we also have detected genes fusions that
are forming less than one percent of
patients we have got
red positive patients here you can see
nicely the imbalance of the three prime
five prime prof uh ratio and here you
can see
this is the um the positivity or
the signal for the specific variant we
also have
patients with and track fusion we have
one patient but it's
over and for positive case and we also
have
several cross-positive cases and the
important thing is that
all base all these patients have been
detected
upfront and diagnosed which means that
you can give the best opportunity at the
beginning
of treatment and encounter medics
unfortunately skipping it's another
important gene alteration that it's
uh gaining an importance
in in lung cancer because there are
several drugs can maternity topotenants
have lymphedema that are getting
really good results this is a technique
which has
no standard for uh for detection unlike
like
or was and while recommendations are
using our tpcr
or ngs so we i meant to see
if by using the same uh approach by
using different
barcodes and props um by
uh binding them to the exon13
14 and exon 15 from the chain we could
identify
those patients that had all those tumors
ahead this keeping
at exon 14 with the same approach seeing
if we could see
an imbalance between those patients with
a complete gene of those patients that
had
an rna splicing which is what is giving
the oncogenicity
and we did it and the results are
fantastic we have
identified several methods on 14
skipping results as you can see here the
ratios
changes completely and you specifically
identify the rna which is spliced and we
have confirmed all the cases with
our rtpcr and with seconds
and this is one of the most important
slides on my presentations as seen june
2007 to
april 2020 nanostring has been able to
identify
a nine percent of dragon ball gene
adorations
among the most common one
we have identified 11 patients which is
almost a four percent of incidents in
our population of patients which is very
similar to other eastern countries
rose red and track are really rare
uh really rare alterations but
well if you put them together you see
that we have had
five patients that have been able to
receive targeted therapies
uh specific targeted therapies for this
alteration and one of the most important
things
is met exam 14 alterations we identify
a four percent uh incidence in our
patients which is
higher than the uh translocation and
alkaline
location and puts it as a one of the
major
or most important target alterations
that can
soon be incorporated in the clinical
practice
and this is my last part the last part
of my presentation
one of the important things was to
demonstrate which was the usefulness of
encounter
in lanca in lung cancer in terms of
outcomes and i'm glad to
share with you that one with cargo we
had our second paper except
accepted it's open access and you can
find it in cancers
and it was the idea here was if we
wanted to use nanostring
we had to put a nanostring together
with the the other technique which is
dna for the detection
of all genetic alterations not only in
rna but also in dna
so and this is uh how we are
handling right now in our
hospital the the identification or the
molecular characterization for lung
cancer patients we are using
in tissue we are using next generation
sequencing on combined to identify
alterations at dna mutations
and we are using encounter for
identification for the identification
or gene fusion and met exon 14 skipping
mutations
and it was very important to create our
own floor
chair for paraffin tissue processing
and this is very important because i
mentioned it before tissue samples in
lung cancer
are scarce and very are very tiny so we
have 200
very in a very um optimal way
these samples and as you can see here
the
slides section for the encounter
are sectioned up from
together with the immunohistochemistry
uh
diagnosed um techniques at the beginning
of the cutting of the formaldehyde
fix parfait embedded tumor
and this is the goal to patients we we
evaluated
uh we were able to evaluate a total of
172 patients
that had results for dna and rna
but the churchill court for some
patients we could not
uh get information with rna and we
rescue them with other techniques
immunochemistry
or fees for and the total court included
121 patients
and this is very nice illustration of
the computational plot
howard our data revealed you similarly
to other
tcga publication previously those are
only advanced non-small cell and cancer
patients in here
on your left you can see the gene
alterations and
and the columns are the different
patients that are
grouped by gene alteration as you can
see here and it's very nice because
you can see how the different oncogenic
alterations
are exclusive it means that the tumor
is only dependent on one of the reasons
so once you have an issue for mutation
you don't have
a null fusion or a rose fusion and this
data it's very important because
also corroborate that our results
are good and here are the pies or
for the incidence of our population of
patients
in hospital clinic for the total number
of 191 patients
you can see here the most common genital
duration of course was
keras which is the most common because
it's the most common
in smokers in patients with smoking
habits
but those here are with this different
color
color are the ones that we are most
proud about which are
all the genetic alterations that we were
able to
identify with nanostring and that
made that the total number of patients
with an oncogenic driver
in our population rise to 68 percent
and here you can see how nicely the
different colors and the incidents of
the different alterations
change according to smoking habits and
agenda and this is my last
slide and this is one of the most
important of my presentation
which was to demonstrate that if we
gave specific targeted therapies to
these
patients with the specific genetic
alterations identified either with
nanostring or with ngs dna
ngs we could improve overall survival it
means that it was
worthy to give specific targeted
approaches to those patients and you can
see here on your
right how in red how those patients that
cat harbor and oncogenic driver that
were treated with a specific targeted
therapy
had an improved significantly improve
overall survival for more than two years
as compared
compared to those patients with driver
or no
target therapy with no targeted therapy
or those patients with no
driver and with that i want to conclude
my presentation i want to thank uh
dr pratt for your his continued support
all the oncology thoracic oncology you
need
my collaborators and the clinic and in
the lab
i also want to thank the spanish
ministry of health for the grant they
provide me to do all these
um research and also our collaborators
in pangakhaya they shares
thank you so much for your attention
so dr reward let me let me ask a few
questions
one particular question would be how old
can the
ffpe tissue blocks be is there an
expiration date pass with the quality of
rna
is no longer good for using on the
encounter in your experience
so this is a very important uh question
epic that often comes out because when
we are working on with the rna normally
we have in mind that rna is easily
degraded
and when we are using a really old
paraffin
um for monday fixed paraffin embedded
tissues that have been
stored for a long time that the rna is
not going
to be good enough quality it's not going
to be good enough for
nanostring but this is not a
nanostring it's not uh it doesn't use
simplification
of the rna for for testing it's
counting cortical counting for digital
uh analysis so it doesn't need any
enzymatic
reaction and in our experience we have
seen
that uh perfume uh
blocks really old uh all those
uh 15 years uh are good enough
for doing the testing so we don't have
any uh expertise date
two for uh testing with nanostring we
always try it
and the majority of times we have got
good results
i could say that it's more important the
quantity the amount of the rna you have
in there
rather than the uh the age
of this perfume embedded tissue
block
i think another question that i was
really uh
intrigued about is what can you repeat
oh can you tell us
what is the minimum rna input required
for the particular assay you're using in
the clinic
as i mentioned before i think a minimum
of
rna yes is important it's important that
when the sample is taken as i shown at
the beginning this flow chart
uh which are which is
always implemented in the pathology at
the beginning
of the diagnose and the tissue
management of lung cancer patients
it's very important to check if there
are
enough cells for for
testing testing not only for nanostring
but also for ngs because the
requirements
are quite similar um the total number of
samples
we have uh seen that a total and
reach total number of tumor samples of
600
1000 it's enough and um
if we talk about the input rna input
the optimum it's 200 nanometers to be
sure that you are going to have results
but we have seen we have had also
positive cases with a minimum of 25
nanograms of rna which is a very low
amount
of rna so i could say that
in daily clinic practice i would say if
you have enough tumor cells go ahead
don't look at the age of the perfume and
blood tumor sample
and don't look at the quantity of rna
because you would get surprised how
nicely nanostream performs
with very small amounts of rna
in addition what do you prioritize if
the material
in the sample is not enough for both dna
and rna analysis what would be
your priority for lung cancer patients
today
well this is a very good question it
depends right now with the covet i have
to say that we are prioritizing rna
and nano string because we are no longer
we are no longer able to do um
on combined because the pathology
department is really busy doing
rt pcr for college so we are very very
lucky
that we can we have nanostring at least
to identify the other
a bunch of genes but if we do have
um a tumor that have very small
amount of tissue samples normally we
prioritize a nanostring but not because
the genes
are more important or less important
it's because
as i showed you before nanostring slides
um are have been incorporated at the
beginning
of the tissue handling or processing of
the samples because
the slides for nanoscreen are followed
to those used for um diagnose in
monostochemistry
and after that we change and then we
start doing
all the sectioning for oncoming
and for easy of our detection for
example we can use
other blockchain needs such as covas
and normally we prefer to go for
nanostring and in tissue uh with pdl1
at the beginning of the diagnostic world
cup
and then continue with the oncoming
if we do not have enough samples needed
for
uncombined dna or rna then we have the
climate study which is a
blood sampling ngs study in our center
in which we are able to do
ngsm in blood
another question is how does the
encounter perform
compared to other techniques that are
also implemented today
such as rtpcr or next generation
sequencing
for the detection of the met skipping
mutation
what is your experience and what are the
differences among the different assays
this is a good question and there is
very little doubt about
it and we are our third paper right now
ongoing and we already have it written
so we hope it's going to be our third
paper
with a nanostring it performs
very very well and when we have
our paper out you will see really nice
data because nanostring can give
a further information uh
will be beyond the skipping expectation
14
skipping a duration about the
amplification
or the expression of the gene and those
have been
um biomarkers that have not
had really great success when um
exploring targeted approaches but maybe
it was because we were not using
the optimal biomarkers so i cannot talk
more about that but i think
um our data is going to give a lot more
information about this
novel gene which is meditation 14
skipping
so with my presentation i have shown you
how nanostring
performed really nicely to identify
several gene fusions
and also novel gene alterations such as
n-track um such as
metrics on protein escaping mutation
which are very important currently to
prioritize targeted therapies in these
advanced non-small cell lung cancer
patients
which have really poor prognostics
and in which targeted therapies can
can improve the outcomes
nanostring is a really high throughput
to make it the samples we are using can
be
very old you can use it with very small
amounts of rna i mean it's very useful
to be used at least in lung cancer
because this is
are the perfect
conditions that we need for our
tumor samples and we hope in the future
we have been able also to incorporate
nanostream in the routine world cup
in our hospital and very glad of that
and i think that our final data and
clinical data corroborate that we have
really good results and nano streams are
really
useful to technology to be used
um as well as other um dna and gs
techniques
in the management of the diagonal and
the diagnostic
management of solid
tumors and thank you so much for your
attention